à main sur Loire le long de la rivière
des mauves existe un endroit particulier
un ancien marécage drainé à l'époque
gallo-romaine pour canaliser l'eau et
ainsi alimenter une trentaine de Moulins
le paysage se transforme canaux et il
eau relié par des ponts
dans les années 50 les moulins
s'arrêtent et le paysage redevient
sauvage
pierre Paris de botanique décide en 1987
d'aménager le lieu pour y planter une
collection de houx où il est
150 espèces qui deviennent un objet de
curiosité pour spécialiste du monde
entier
certains botanistes sont appris que nous
avions une collection de Wi-Fi ils sont
venus visiter cette collection et à
partir de 91 nous avons été labellisés
collection nationale par le CCV
c'est-à-dire par le conservatoire des
collections végétales spécialisées
pierre encouragé par cette
reconnaissance plante et étudie 400 îles
ex venus d'Allemagne du Japon de Chine
des États-Unis où il est considéré comme
une plante d'ornement à part entière
le houx que nous avons n'a qu'une seule
espèce en Europe là qu'il faut l'ium il
faut savoir qu'actuellement on a 800
espèces connues dans le monde et quand
je prends rien qu'une seule espèce aux
États-Unis qui est le PACA ils ont mille
variétés commercialisées
je prends l'espèce crédata au Japon ils
ont 800 variétés commercialisées en
France avec notre aquifolium on les
compte sur les doigts des deux mains on
regrette beaucoup que la plante qui soit
de collection qui déplantera qui soient
pas mises plus au commerce pour nos
jardins
le houx au feuillage persistant vert et
piquant est un des symboles de Noël
mais sous d'autres contrées il peut être
d'un aspect très différent
sur deux hectares aujourd'hui
l'arboretum des prédéculents présentent
d'autres végétaux érables bambou
cornouillés climatite et plantes
aquatiques
en 2004 l'arboretum et labellisé jardin
remarquable il accueille 1500 visiteurs
par an
si la vocation pédagogique il est tout
d'abord lieu de conservation
le but de l'arboretum c'est surtout de
conserver des végétaux
d'implanter des végétaux qui sont en
white disparition et de suivre le
développement nous travaillons de façon
à éviter toutes les pertes de végétaux
que nous avons dans le monde c'est par
milliers de végétaux qui disparaissent
par an et donc dans les certains pays où
nous avons des végétaux qui sont en voie
de disparition
on en implante dans les arboretums de
façon que le jour s'ils sont tous
disparus on sait ou on retrouve
mon histoire à moi tout simplement mes
parents étaient viticulteurs et puis moi
j'aimais bien j'aimais la terre et je
suis lancé dans l'horticulture j'ai fait
l'école d'horticulture j'ai été
jardinier à la ville d'Orléans ensuite
j'ai été responsable horticole du Parc
Floral de la Source et puis de là à la
retraite et bien je me suis lancé à
faire mon parc aussi
pierre a toujours eu à coeur de
transmettre ses connaissances botaniques
rappelez-vous il a été pendant 20 ans le
jardinier de France Bleu Orléans
aujourd'hui du haut de ses 70 ans Pierre
sait qu'il laisse au futur un outil
précieux de compréhension et d'études du
paysage